PETE: I think one of the interesting things
you guys are doing here is related to fraud
prevention.
How do you guys stop online fraud?
VIDA: Right.
Well, it's a really important issue for us
because anytime you're giving out something
for free, there's a possibility that fraud
is going to creep into the system and just
make your whole product kind of worthless
to your retailer.
So, we looked at some point into using IP
addresses, knowing bad IP addresses from users,
looking at why browsers the kind of traditional
way to fight fraud.
And then we realized we had such a rich set
of signals from the social data.
So, we have from our first campaign from Skype
that we know so far, we launched a campaign
there, where you could if you like you can
get a free Skype code.
We found that our fraud raise were better
than industry average, basically because we
have a social data to tell us whether the
user was fraudulent or not.
So, if you think about it, it's really hard
for someone to have signed-up for a multiple,
it's so easy to sign-up for multiple email
accounts.
I'm sure we all have several, the one that
don't you just give real people, those things.
With the Facebook want is it becomes really
apparent which account is real and not real
because you have more friends on your real
account, you update it more often.
We get all that data to know how often does
someone update their status, what is their
profile picture, how many friends do they
have, such a rich set of data that even though,
our algorithms we started I think they're
solid.
I don't think we've, by any means, gone to
the limits of our social data fraud filtering
capability but because of signals are so strong,
we're actually able to get a really good signal.
PETE: That's very interesting.
Are you using aggregated social data from
different social nets or is it mostly Facebook
that has the biggest use to you right now?
VIDA: Facebook is the biggest use to us right
now because Facebook credits are the most
popular incentives that we're offering.
PETE: I see.
VIDA: We have a Twitter product where you
can incentivize someone tweeting.
We haven't actually used it for social data
fraud for fraud filtering right now.
PETE: Got it, okay.
So, if I'm an engineer and I'm building an
application and I want to stop online fraud,
what's the first thing I should do?
VIDA: I think engineers will tend to design
an algorithm for it - instead think of things
that you can do and natural signals out there
because your AI algorithms as crazy and complicated
as they are only going to be as good as your
signals.
If Facebook is actually, Facebook Connect
is pretty decent, you can check if an account
is verified or not.
It needs to be verified by a mobile phone
number rather than just an email account or
something that's easy, you know, everyone
has limited mobile phones.
I would actually really even consider policy
things.
That's my tendency, is to go with the practical.
PETE: One of the interesting things that we
talked about before was when you mentioned
that the online fraud doesn't always come
- It's not always a trickle.
It often comes in sort of a blast like one
big storm.
Explain that phenomenon and what that means.
VIDA: I think what happens, we actually had,
so what happened for a while was that there
was a number of people who figured out a credit
card number that worked on one of our retailer
sites that wasn't a real credit card number
or maybe it was a stolen credit card number,
I don't even know.
It just got out.
They must have posted about it in a forum
or things like that.
So, all of a sudden overnight we had tons
of fraud that came in one big burst because
what happens is one person figures out how
to fraud the system.
What's the first thing they're going to do?
They're going to spread the word to all their
friends.
Especially since what we do a lot is Facebook
credits.
So, these are people who play games or used
to gifting their friend's things everyday
and they gift it with the ability to fraud.
So, we'll basically get a big burst of fraud
in one night and have to figure out the, figure
out the signal that will get rid of this fraud
and then push it within 10 minutes.
So, I'm going to change to shut this down.
The first thing you want to do is come up
with some kind of control or some kind of
a velocity control.
So, you can realize when there's a potential
for fraud to alert yourself for it that it
could be happening because you're not realistically
monitoring these things every day.
PETE: The velocity of some particular metric
or set of metrics that you're kind of watching
across time.
VIDA: Right.
A particular campaign just seems to be picking
up speed and it's just a little bit suspicious.
So that's the first piece to code up which
is difficult.
It's not straight forward how to calculate
that kind of thing.
And then when you go in to it you can look
at the data and pretty quickly come up with
some kind of signal.
I think that's actually easy part, is coming
up with some kind of signal when you look
at, as a person when you look at just five
or ten of these fraudulent users you can usually
find some characteristics pretty quickly that
they all have in common.